how much like time do you have to watch
anime nowadays then do you still watch
it a lot i am actually this year i'm
trying to culture myself by consuming
more uh-huh so that's what i've been
doing so what are you guys what are you
starting with well well okay this is not
anime related
oh yeah i really liked it what the [ __ ]
does that have to do with your anime
culture no no no culturing in general
just like catching up on stuff whole i
don't think holes is like a classic
movie oh really wait holes is the one
with the buff yeah
that's not that's it's not like uh
they're not like they're departed
godfather shawshank redemption halls
do not [ __ ] ask titus what the
classic movies are i liked it
what else movies do you suggested uh
well i watched the lord of the rings
trilogy
i wasn't a huge fan of the whole movie i
i didn't even watch the second or third
i was so bored on the first really
i like it's not the same it's not so
wait let's go back what anime are you
playing yeah yeah oh well now i'm trying
to keep up more with the current anime
because i've been watching like spy
family
and also because i'm like i'm seeing it
everywhere and i'm like well i have to
watch it yeah like you hear everyone
talking about it nowadays especially
for like at least 10 minutes if you just
know like the names of like five atoms
yeah if you just be like i like spare
family that's like an hour conversation
right there yeah yeah yeah exactly i do
i i did wha i see a lot of detective
conan yeah and i did like watching
detective conan when i was younger yeah
back in like middle school but there's
so many episodes you only need to watch
like three episodes of detective conan's
be like yeah i get it i get it like we
talk about it
let's be honest there's like it ain't
that dude it gets really good teenager
in kid body solves
exactly bam what else you need to know
about detective code all i'm gonna say
is it gets better in the manga
shut the [ __ ] up it does god you don't
have to watch the movies just no no no
no trust i see tokyo revengers
everywhere
is it good
it starts really strong kind of
[ __ ] it's okay yeah
what else what else
i gotta even say
i finished demonstrating
why because i tried reading it and it i
thought it was really ugly well yeah
well
actually no even 10 year olds you watch
and you can't even handle attack on
titan yeah it's different no it's yeah
it is
a lot worse
it's different okay i feel like horror
is different you like you know
no no no so you think you want you cause
you're expecting it like yeah you're
like yeah people are gonna die i'm ready
for this well then why don't you go into
attack on titan expecting people to die
because
i don't know
i just never got it did you enjoy like
another then did you watch another back
in the day another yeah the one that was
literally just like gore amv yeah yeah
no okay okay i don't like gory stuff
like whole animals
you watched higurashi
i was in middle school that's gory as
[ __ ] i was in middle school i could
handle it back then
child you could handle it better than
adult you
you're like you feel like benjamin
button
younger like
when i was a kid i was like i'm gonna
look at all dodgy edgy stuff yeah i like
i i i like creepy things
and now i'm just slenderman
i'm like man i just want to like enjoy
the stuff i'm confused
yeah i feel like ever since we started
talking about anime we've just put emily
on like the podium it's just like tell
me your taste i was objection objection
based on like the stuff i've told you
kind of get a feel for like what might
you do yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
if i see like an anime like wrap up
video
i'm like alright what am i interested in
and it's like
new goofy anime haha funny laughs and
i'm like i'm going to watch that one
[Laughter]
is it like like uh what was the last one
like nagatoro did you like that one
well you
uh comey can't communicate got boring
for me it looked boring it got kind of
boring wow you just called out like
every single comey simple i'm sorry it
looks kind of boring very cute watch you
don't talk though just open your mouth i
tried to get that
it looks like one of those shows it
would be really endearing for like six
episodes and i'd be like i kind of feel
like i've seen everything
it's okay
shut the [ __ ] up
like like shut the [ __ ] isn't it is it
is it bad that i can see i can see a
premise and like the kind of like just
passing scenes and i can be like i can
already tell what this experience is
going to be and i'm fine not having to
be fair
if if i were to come to comic son's
defense there is like a romantic
development that gets really [ __ ]
good
what's that one romance anime i got
invested and then gave up on in high
school
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah i tried getting into
horry mia i couldn't do it or mia or me
gets boring off the like volume 8 god so
many of these like i know they're all
different but in my mind they're just
they occupy the same space of show
yeah horror mia and uh
they just seem like the same show yeah
they're just they're right
yeah they're just
i think like what really separates dress
up darling is literally just the main
characters yeah you know they they just
they actually
felt like really interesting characters
that weren't just like your typical you
know
happy-go-lucky romance characters a lot
of the time to be fair though i'm like
catching up with i've like caught up
with the manga for
dress-up darling and the latest volume
was kind of boring and i was like oh
please don't hurry me up this [ __ ]
please i beg of you don't get boring
yeah because because the thing about
praying yeah because the thing about
things like
like nagato especially in like komisan
it's just like it's kind of the same
show just like with a different gimmick
like oh this time the girl can't speak
and you know it's it's the story of like
you know it's it's a it's a fun
happy-go-lucky story but the girl can't
speak or like nagatorio she's the bully
and then after like around seven volumes
that i think everyone starts to realize
it's like oh all right i'm not sure if
we can milk out this one any
a
further
i want to know if you like because i
feel like it it has a few things uh do
you like re zero
i haven't seen it oh
okay why do you think emily will like it
i don't know there is some gore in there
obviously but there's also the trashy
romance aspect subaru doesn't look
interesting to me
like another loser and attractor you you
do that
you're gonna do that and then you'll
literally like watch fruit baskets and
then be like
i was just like you know i don't want to
be like that that [ __ ] who's just
like yeah
it's just like you just don't get it but
like
[Laughter]
you don't have it you don't have a deep
enough intellect to understand raise
your hand
high enough
no i mean like one of the great things
about subaru is that he's passed off as
like a loser and attracts super then he
gets a lot of development okay like
actually like has to deal with the fact
that like he's cringe and like yeah yeah
yeah yeah the whole story is about how
yo bro you cringe like you you you
[Laughter]
that's literally the show yeah i would
consider i'll consider watching yeah
you'll like it and then because i know
that you'll you'll have a lot to say
about it that's why i think you should
watch it yeah both i think i think
you'll have a lot to say and you'll go
off on one i can see it's being one of
those shows where you'll just go off i
just want you to watch the show just so
i could hear your opinion yeah because i
know you're going to have such a strong
opinion it's definitely going to be a
discussion yeah yeah you should watch it
because the thing is she had this much
to say about jiu-jitsu and i was just
like i didn't even have this much
seriously
i talk about anime from a living i was
just like i remember like when we
switched
anime list and then emily went off about
toradora for like 40 minutes and then i
ended with like i like it yeah i guess
it was like it's good beat here what
tordora's like aos dude huh torado's
like soa for me
[ __ ] off anyway [ __ ] off dude
don't wash your like silver spoon or
some [ __ ] what do you like is a good
shot
take that back